yagg la main castanic et
d'applaudissements pour lui ben jamin
castagne et gilles verdez comment ça va
mais chéri très bien oui alors castaldi
qu'as tu tombe bien vos chiens déjà
cette nouvelle voiture
comment tu peux l'enlever ouais ouais au
moins contre connaît comment savoir mon
chéri très bien chanté une forme mon
chéri j'ai une question à trois ils pas
ce que je lis la presse la presse people
ouais je vais tomber sur le public de
cette semaine
et qu'est ce que je vois après trois
divorces et trois enfants
il remet ça benjamin castaldi aurore est
enceinte donc sa femme est enceinte sa
femme attend un heureux des veines des
moments qu'on peut l'annoncer ou est ce
que c'est des conneries ou est ce que
l'on donne rien dire ou es ce que les
jeunes aiment ça allait à cyril ferry
construit rejouer fais ce que tu le sais
depuis un moment et tu n'as rien dit
donc bravo à toi car tu vas tu aurais
plus beau que ça peut faire un petit
coucou à l'antenne du l'a pas fait donc
je suis très flatté permet de bien
et oui c'est vrai et garçons mathis en
aéro petit garçon bazhenov pas
franchement ça fait plaisir
alors tu sais quoi j'ai hésité
je vais j'hésite entre lino mais monfils
s'entend bien voilà et ce sera peut-être
angelo parce que c'est le nom de mon
grand père je sais pas encore où je ne
sais pas noah un italien voit la mine
lino angelo aubert sinon un nom italien
tu as jean-luc vaches étaient heureux
très heureux très heureux oui bien sûr
je très heureuse donc pas ce que tu es
heureux
voilà on est on perd quelqu'un qui porta
femme ou pas mais je te dire allez y est
on a eu quatre jours qui était un peu
stressant parce que c'était un peu de la
sidération c'est vrai que pour eux
voilà avec un bébé dans le ventre toutes
les histoires du virus et c'est un peu
compliqué c'est vrai que l est très
angoissée des zones naturelles mais là
encore plus mais bon là là maintenant
j'ai l'impression qu'elle a pris un peu
la mesure de 2,2 ce qu'on vit est bon
voilà on s'occupe comme on peut et puis
on prend soin d'elle on dit que c est
mon bonheur tous les matins
ces recettes car ça te permet de garder
le cap mon chéri garder le moral
exactement exactement est-ce que je
t'aime a énormément mon chéri tu manques
évidemment vos banques et au sommeil à
pailles acquis à toi bien sûr bien toute
l'équipe depuis depuis des années ces
belles équipes et tout le monde manque
mais bon on reste en contact moi j'ai
beaucoup de gens téléphonent de l'équipe
honda noël un peu tout le monde et c'est
vrai que mais c'est vrai que c'est là on
se rend compte qu à la bouche on est une
vraie famille voilà c'est on se parle
par écrans interposés c'est c'est sympa
mais on préfère bon on préfère se voit
alors est-ce que tu as choisi le parrain
de ton fils est ce que je vais te poser
je te proposer des noms est-ce que ça va
être jean michel maire
non est-ce que ça va être
isabelle morini-bosc la marraine non non
pas ce qu'avait rapt est pas la
naissance alors est algérien on embrasse
isa que j'ai ma chérie ce sera gilles
verdez and on and on donc possible pas
possible et matthieu delormeau
non non non non non non non non non non
je les regarde les gains solides que
quelqu'un de avec des épaules quelqu'un
qui est de la six qui est de la
puissance quelqu'un qui pourra assurer
enquêtes en cas de départ anticipé de ma
personne et donc je t'ai choisi
non vraiment bah oui c'est bien je
souhaitais je t'ai choisi comme parrain
bien sûr donc c'était pas les toits mais
on sait pas une vanne je suis vraiment
je serais vraiment le parrain de son
fils
je te remonter mais je croyais mais non
un métier que ça me touche énormément
mon chéri je suis très heureux que tu
sois le parrain de ce petit way et je me
touche énormément et bien sûr je ferai
tout pour qu'il soit heureux je te le
dis comme ça j'en suis sûr déjà j'en
suis sûr j'en suis sûr voilà ça me fait
plaisir mon chéri tu as envie de te
faire du 13 heures repas mais je te fais
des gros bisous en tout cas la même
temps l'on s'attend à voir et la nature